vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir les réactions
se multiplient à bamako au lendemain de
la diffusion sur l'autre antenne de
l'entretien du premier ministre malien
on écoutera à tailhades mohammed membre
signataire de l'accord de paix d'alger
il réagit aux propos de choguel maïga
sur l'opération serval de 2013 et sur la
présence des mercenaires russes wagner
deux ans et demi de transition burkina
faso un mois après le coup d'état
militaire la jungle s'est vu remettre un
rapport par une commission qu'elle a
constituée chargée de plancher sur la
transition et les futurs projets les
détails à suivre dans ce journal
est notre invité ce soir est un rappeur
qui puise dans le quotidien de ses
compatriotes congolais pour faire des
compositions enlevé entraînante il est
lauréat du prix et ré découverte rfi
2021 à laich et sur le plateau du
jourdain de l'offre
[Musique]
on ouvre ce journal par les réactions
suscitées par les propos du premier
ministre malien sur notre antenne hier
soir choguel maïga était notamment
revenu sur l'opération serval en 2013 en
minimisant le rôle des français dans la
libération de tombouctou je vous propose
d'écouter hatay abou mohamed responsable
à bamako du suivi de l'accord de paix
d'alger c'est l'accord qu'est mis fin au
conflit entre le gouvernement malien et
les rebelles de la coordination des
mouvements de l'azawad en 2015 il est au
micro de notre correspondante à bamako
anne-flore lespiau
peut-être que on pourrait m'accuser ddt
pas le rang de la france loin de là la
france se suffire à elle-même pour
répondre à ce qui a été dit contre elle
mais pour l'histoire est vraiment même
il est important
de reconnaître qu en 2013 la rue
malienne était bel et bien appuyé par
milliers par les forces navales et que
les villes de tombouctou de gao
quasiment il en existe encore pour ceux
qui veulent vérifier où ce sont bien les
biens les forces françaises qui met les
villes à disposition des femmes et ceci
n'était pas un secret ceci d'ailleurs
étaient considérés comme étant de grands
succès diffusée sur la chaîne nationale
malienne mais de ce fait il ne faut pas
aussi faire comme s'ils avaient mali
n'était pas là elle était là mais il est
important de reconnaître les efforts des
autos dans notre accompagnement fire the
game à égal à 10 hier soir le mali
travail avec la coopération russe
d'après le premier ministre leterme
wagner aurait été inventé par la france
vous êtes un acteur originaire du nord
du pays où vous déplacer très
régulièrement avez vous pu observer la
présence de wagner
calmement nos forces ont constaté en
compagnie des forces maliennes des
individus de plus en plus nombreux ce
qu'ont constaté les trains c'est
exactement les modes opératoires de
force et non conventionnelles si vous
voulez des mercenaires qui constitue un
quart des individus au sein de farce
régaliennes que l'on appuie on parle
beaucoup ces dernières semaines de la
montée en puissance de l'armée malienne
qui affirme avoir rétabli la sécurité
dans plusieurs localités du centre et du
nord du pays notamment dans la zone des
trois frontières
en tant que membre signataire de
l'accord de paix
que pensez-vous de la réponse militaire
des autorités et quelles sont vos
attentes qu'entend quant à la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord de paix d'alger et 6
et 7 monte en puissance et fait dans l
aspect n'est ce pas dès lors de la
guerre voilà que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut s'allier par ailleurs il nous
est difficile nous en tant qu'acteur et
nous ne sommes pas laisser les pensées
en ce moment en vérifiant des prêts
qu'ils aient beaucoup de ces choses sont
difficiles à confirmer et nous l'avons
dit ya quelques jours nous les plus
importants aujourd'hui c'est la sécu
tribulations on est allé à muse et dcsp
d'aller vite des métrages synergie des
efforts pour contribuer efficacement à
cette sécurité mais notre objectif le
plaisir team c'est arrivé à mettre en
place leurs conseillers localement les
mouvements qu'ils ont opposé dès 1500
glauco
avoir
un pacte citoyen du pays dans cette
phase dans sa constitution à travers son
effectif que chercheur qui certainement
va refléter l'image de tous les pays
cinq soldats tchadiens ont été tués par
des djihadistes la taxe est produite
dans la région du lac tchad devenu un
repère important pour le groupe
terroriste
boko haram état islamique et ils
conduisent régulièrement des attaques
contre les militaires et les civils dans
toute la zone
on passe au burkina faso où la junte au
pouvoir depuis le coup d'état d'il ya un
mois envisage à présent une période de
transition de 30 mois c'est-à-dire deux
ans et demi avant les prochaines
élections une commission chargée de
l'élaboration des projets de l'agenda de
la transition a été mis sur pied le 8
février dernier et elle a remis un
rapport ce mercredi à la présidence les
grandes lignes du rapport avec notre
correspondant kalidou sy
deux semaines après leur installation
les 15 membres de la commission
technique chargée de la transition ont
remis ce jour leur rapport au président
damiba dans une cérémonie au palais
kossyam ce rapport est composé du projet
pour la charte constitutionnelle pour la
transition de l'agenda de la transition
et d'une charte des valeurs pour
soutenir la refondation selon une source
proche de la présidence la durée
proposée de transition et de 30 mois car
selon cette même source
l'armée a fait part de son besoin d'au
moins deux ans pour stabiliser le pays
niveau sécuritaire puis organiser des
élections autre recommandation la
formation d'un gouvernement composé de
15 à 20 membres au maximum la mise en
place d'un organe législatif de la
transition avec 51 membres qui
regrouperait l'ensemble des composantes
de la nation c'est-à-dire la société
civile le politique et le militaire sans
oublier les autorités religieuses et
coutumières leur mandat ne seraient pas
rémunérées également recommandé un
organe de veille de la transition mais
lens civils et militaires pour le suivi
et l'évaluation de la mise en place de
la transition avec là aussi un mandat
sans rémunération voilà pour les
principales recommandations du rapport
de la commission technique chargée de la
transition prochaine étape pour le
président damiba la formation d'un
gouvernement de transition qui devrait
vraisemblablement survenir dans les
prochains jours
annonce surprise qui vient d'alice abeba
le premier ministre éthiopien ouvre la
porte à des négociations avec les
groupes rebelles du tplf habilla remède
a néanmoins souligné que ces pourparlers
n'avaient pas commencé pour rappel la
guerre est en cours depuis novembre 2020
entre le pouvoir central et les rebelles
de la région du tigré des milliers de
personnes ont été tuées et quelques deux
millions de personnes ont été
contraintes de fuir leurs foyers en
raison des violences
on vous en parlait hier le cyclone est
menacée a frappé madagascar et les
secours sont à pied d'oeuvre pour venir
en aide aux habitants qui ont déjà
souffert après le passage de plusieurs
tempêtes tropicales depuis un mois pour
l'heure aucun bilan humain n'est
disponible
au kenya le président kenyan atteint
après deux mandats à la tête du pays ne
pouvait plus se représenter
il devait donc soutenir un candidat pour
le scrutin d'août 2022 et au lieu d'
adoubé son vice président william ruto
il a annoncé qu'il soutiendrait son
éternel rival raila odinga
la correspondance à nairobi de bastien
rozeaux
s'exprimer devant les anciens de la
région du mont kenya ces leaders
politiques et communautaires extrêmement
important lui avait demandé il ya
plusieurs mois de dire qu'il allait
soutenir lors de l'élection d'août 2022
eh bien ce sera raila odinga alors la
chose n'est pas surprenante pour les
observateurs de la politique kenyane
puisque depuis l'épisode de la poignée
de mains en 2018 qui avait mis fin aux
tensions postélectorales suite au
scrutin contesté de 2017
les deux hommes s'afficher régulièrement
ensemble mettez régulièrement scène leur
bonne entente dans les médias ce qui
n'était pas le cas entre ou kenyatta il
son vice président william ruto qu'il
aurait normalement dû soutenir durant
cette élection c'était le contrat entre
les deux hommes william ruto accepté
d'être vice président durant deux
mandats et ensuite bien ils étaient
autour douro kenyatta de le soutenir
durant ses campagnes suivantes mais ce
ne sera pas le cas oui la moto est
ostracisé depuis des mois il ne fait
plus réellement partie du gouvernement
il ne fait plus partie des grandes
décisions prises par ouvre kenyatta
c'est une véritable trahison pour ses
soutiens d'autres y voient même une
façon pour hogan iata de rester en
politique une fois ses deux mandats
achevée en tirant les ficelles d'une
marionnette cette marionnette se serait
selon le rail à odinga pour raïla odinga
en tout cas bien cette fois ci c'est
peut-être la bonne après quatre
élections malheureuse il a toujours été
dans l'opposition maintes fois chef de
l'opposition même cette fois ci ce sera
peut-être la bonne puisque outre
kenyatta est un soutien de poids pour
obtenir des votes dans des régions qui
nous y sont pas acquises et qui sont
extrêmement difficiles à obtenir pour
lui toujours est il que cette fois ci la
campagne électorale kényane est
réellement lancé pour ce scrutin qui
aura lieu en août 2022
notre invité de ce soir est un chante
chronique rappeur éveilleur de
conscience qui est tombé dans la musique
très jeune à l'âge de 15 ans je me suis
essayée dire qu'il a découvert un micro
et s'est lancé dans les chroniques
musicales pour la télévision nationale
congolaise à la chirugie sa vie à lech
est avec nous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir dans le merci à vous ou alors vous
êtes le tout nouveau prix rfi le prix
découvertes rfi 2021 on vous avait reçu
donc le 17 décembre via skype lorsque
vous avez reçu le prix officiellement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis pour
vous qu'est ce que ce prix a changé pour
vous non mais énormément de choses
énormément de choses faut faut dire
c'est un prix qui a un rayonnement
international et que c'est un énorme
accomplissement pour un pour un
chanteur africain de pouvoir dessert de
pouvoir recevoir ce genre de prix
en plus il faut dire moi je suis le
deuxième comolet à recevoir ce prix
c'est un énorme accomplissement surtout
en regardant d'où je viens de ma ville
kisangani j'ai vu le film de ma carrière
défilé devant mes yeux en deux trois
secondes donc ouais ce ce prix
représente énormément de choses pour moi
qu'est ce qui a changé et ben déjà les
dates
les dates de concerts qui sont qui sont
à venir la considération même au sein de
la communauté et même l'attention que la
communauté accorde aujourd'hui à ma
carrière c'est énormément de choses et
puis il faut dire voilà recevoir ce prix
douze ans après avoir tenté sa chance
quel bel accomplissement oui absolument
et alors deux parmi les nombreuses
choses qui vous arrive dans les nouveaux
projets il y as je suis c'est dire qu'il
y avait un projet de bd de bandes
dessinées qui va retracer votre vie
raconte est exact c'est s était très
importante pour moi
de pallier à une petite faiblesse que
nous avons dans nos communautés la
faiblesse d'entretien de la mémoire faut
dire que ma vie personnelle a été très
marquée profondément marqué par part par
des guerres par par des turbulences
politiques qui ont eu des conséquences
sérieuses sur moi en tant qu'adolescent
à l'époque vivant à kisangani la
troisième ville du pays il faut dire
pour quelques petits exemples à l'âge de
15 ans je me fais est tirée du 1 5 juin
2000 au début de la guerre de six jours
ça c'est des choses que que l'on ne peut
pas oublier
j'ai perdu un frère un grand frère
l'aîné de ma famille à cause des
histoires politiques de la rdc il ya mon
frère à notre grand frère qui avait été
atteint par une balle et setra bref
l'histoire politique
de la rdc
influence fortement ce que je fais est
aujourd'hui étant considéré comme un
modèle au congo et bah écoutez il est
très important pour moi de commencer à
raconter mon histoire mais je me suis
dit qu'il serait important d'enseigner
tous nos drames à nos enfants et de
commencer par les jeunes générations si
j'avais le choix entre écrire un livre
sortir un film où mettre sur pied ce
projet de bd et je me dis ouais il
faudrait peut-être commencer par les
plus jeunes pour qu'ils reflètent pas
les mêmes erreurs donc on commence par
ce projet de bd et c'est un projet qui
sera dévoilée à la fin de la tournée du
prix découvertes rfi et alors qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de dire plus
largement justement cette jeunesse
africaine qui est souvent très peu
souvent entendu sur le continent qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de dire justement
responsables politiques pas simplement à
rdc mais plus largement qu'est-ce que
vous avez avant de parler avant de
parler aux responsables politiques moi
je crois que je m'adresse toujours en
premier lieu aux jeunes nous constituant
plus de 70 % de cette population à vrai
dire c'est nous la vraie force dans les
forces dé sécurité dans les armées dans
les polices dans les délais les agences
de renseignement la vraie main d'oeuvre
c'est des jeunes donc il est très
important que les jeunes soient
solidaires et qu'ils prennent conscience
au fait de la force qu'il constitue pas
c'est généralement les jeunes sont
manipulés par ce qu'ils réalisent pas à
quel point ils sont forts donc en
premier c'est ça et en deuxième lieu aux
responsables politiques moi j'ai envie
de dire comme je le dis toujours le
pouvoir il est passager faut jamais
l'oublier le pouvoir et passagers et de
gré ou de force on finit par passer on a
beau tenter de se maintenir en dix ans
20 ans 30 ans un jour finit par arriver
ou
votre jour au pouvoir sera le dernier et
ça ça peut passer très souvent ça passe
par par une révolte des jeunes est alors
parlez nous de cet album donc l'album
qui est sorti l'année dernière dont on y
voit là le une manière c'est ça que vous
allez jouer justement concert des jeunes
m'asseoir d'ailleurs j'avais déjà marié
j'avais décidé du fait que je venais de
sortir mon deuxième album studio mongo
quelques mois avant l'obtention du prix
rfi
j'avais décidé de lier cet album
c'est album à la tournée africaine et
même à toute la tournée plus de voix la
demande de jeunes en jeu ici à paris
ouais donc voilà c'est le manque d'eau
il est important pour moi de présenter à
différents publics a trait à ce manque
bien sûr donc le monde gong au tour donc
après il y aura une tournée dans 12 pays
dont je rappelle que ce sera aussi sur
sur facebook en facebook live un ce
concert si vous pouvez pas vous déplacer
à la maison de la radio donc c'est ainsi
qu'on referme ce journal afrique merci à
l'est au sud est revenue et j'en profite
pour faire un salut évidemment à tout le
congo de kisangani à kinshasa en passant
par goma partout restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]